Hello and welcome to fire of learning in our education system.
History does for sure account as a core class,
but it's often considered less important than other fields like science,
technology and math.
The reasoning is obvious.
Science and math look toward the future.
They create jobs and are good for the economy,
which is what our public education system is all about.
Meanwhile,
history looks toward the past.
So today I want to ask what benefit to the presence and the future is there in
looking at the past?
Well,
there are indeed several benefits to studying history.
One,
in my opinion is that it satisfies the urge that many of us as humans have to
belong to something greater than ourselves.
The politics we debate in government,
we live under our economics,
our religion,
our language,
or for most people,
languages,
our technology,
our names where we live or holidays,
our clothing,
our culture in general became what they did because of the thousands of years of
history,
the exchange of ideas,
the interactions between peoples and the clashing of empires aren't just boring.
Records of things that happened long before we were born,
their events and to large,
ceaseless story directly responsible for who and what you are and where and how
you live.
A large portion of my ancestors were French Canadian.
They were some of the first colonists in new France and helps build what became
Acadia and Quebec.
Some of my ancestors were Anglo Irish nobility,
which makes me related to rubber boil.
Some of them were simple Welsh quarry men who came here and just built America.
I get two things from knowing this.
The first is a sense of pride and belonging.
Even though I can't take credit for anything my ancestors did and even though I
wasn't there for any of it,
I still feel that through understanding them,
I belonged to the larger framework of human civilization,
I.
E.
Something larger than myself,
closely related to that,
but beyond that,
I feel that understanding myself and my place in the world means understanding
their record of events.
That led up to my existence,
not just human history.
Even looking at things like all the way back at the big bang satisfies the
desire,
but human history is of course the most relatable and most recent,
but all right,
say you don't really care about this,
you don't have these interests in.
You prefer to focus on the future more than finding this meaning and the past
history is still beneficial.
It's an incredibly useful record of mistakes we've made as individuals and as
nations that we can avoid repeating.
If we take the time to objectively analyze what went wrong.
I would go so far as to say that someone who doesn't know history and is trying
to have a major influence on this world is akin with 30 year old trying to live
a good life even though they forgotten 75% of their memories prior to that
point.
You may have to learn all over again.
Don't touch the stove when it's hot.
Don't put a stick in the moving bike wheel,
etc. We can invade Russia,
but keep in mind that the Russians have against the Swedish,
the French,
the Germans and others,
one wars at least in part because they let their very harsh winters decimate
foreign troops.
So if we're going to invade Russia,
let's keep that in mind.
That's a very level example.
I don't know how many of you are applying to invade Russia,
but as I said,
there's plenty of knowledge which can be used in the hands of the individual.
If you want to be rich,
if you want to hold a political office,
if you want it to be a great author or command or scientist or something of that
sort,
you can look at people who were successful in that field.
In the past,
Machiavelli recommends imitating the roles of successful people throughout
history to achieve the same level of success.
Napoleon Bonaparte has a very famous quote about how he as a very successful
general and emperor recommends looking over the conquest of great historic
military leaders like Alexander and Hannibal and other such figures.
To be great in such a field.
It's necessary to understand the mindset that people throughout history have to
examine and contrast conditions that these similar people found themselves in
and those in which you find yourself and to get a good idea of what it takes to
be like them and have similar levels or greater levels of success.
Many of those answers are found and history on an even smaller scale in this
stolen and knowledge of history is crucial and something like the voting polls
and the market and understanding of history may allow you to have a greater
understanding of the conditions of your nation and help you make a responsible
decision in voting for a candidate that your fellow voters are not aware of and
understanding what technologies affects people most significantly and why,
what products people want and when and why they want them.
What are the signs of economic stability or coming catastrophe appear to be you?
For sure.
Again,
a competitive edge in the world brought to you again by history.
As is often said,
those who do not remember the past are doomed to repeat it.
Okay.
For more videos like these and videos on many other subjects.
We should have checked out fire of learning and subscribe.
Thank you for watching.